good morning Hank it's Wednesday check
out the canals right here in
Indianapolis we are the Amsterdam of
central Indiana so Hank today the Yeti
and I are out at 100 acres the art and
nature park that the Indianapolis Museum
of Art is opening this weekend which is
the culmination of years and years of
work by lots of people including the
Yeti so Hank since you and Mom and Dad
can't be here I thought I would give you
a tour so I don't think you know this
but my new book is about an island and
I've been doing a lot of reading about
Islands and one of my favorite projects
here in the 100 acres park is this
awesome tiny little island by ondrea's
Attell called Indianapolis Island so the
crazy thing about that island Hank is
that even though it is tiny and you can
just barely stand up and it 2 people are
living there all summer they've got a
garden growing that extends out into the
water and it's a fascinating experiment
and how little we need in order to live
there's lots of cool trails where you
forget you live in Indianapolis and you
can pretend that you live in I don't
know Missoula this is Eden - a 50-foot
refugee ship created by the artist
Tamaki Paul you know Tamaki Paul Hank
she did TV for chickens this is pretty
awesome to have this weird dislocated
refugee ship sitting on a lake in
Indianapolis cute boots are cute this is
one of yep behinds rollercoaster benches
the only roller coaster I will ever ride
so Sarah tell me about this piece here
this green structure that looks almost
like a TARDIS now this project is a
temporary intervention into the
landscape that will really only be here
for a few days and it's it's point is to
remind us of our humanity this project
is by the artist collective Taipei those
two rings create a single shadow exactly
one day a year the summer solstice we
are almost there as you can see Hank I
am not the only media covering this
event here we have free basket by the
Cuban artists duo Lois carpenter Rose
take what I know about free basket is
that you can actually play provided your
you know willing to invent a new game
like we used to when we were kids it's
like a lot of that work in the park it
forces us to think more complexly about
the shapes and spaces that we often just
look over whether it's benches or
islands or basketball courts which by
the way is why I think people often
dismiss contemporary art overlooking
things as comfortable
I would argue that failing to grapple
with complexity actually turns out to be
a pretty bad life strategy which is why
I like good art so much so I think it's
really good Sara Thanks my only
complaint and please don't take this
personally is that uh you didn't dome it
in so there's no climate control hot
tank there's a ton of other stuff
happening 100 acres more info in the
doobly-doo but I'm not going to tell you
about it because I have to go watch
South Africa play Uruguay I will see you
on Friday